fear is the path to the dark side you
must unlearn what you have feared lost a
planet master obi-wan has how
embarrassing for my Ally is the force
and the powerful it is train yourself to
let go of everything you fear to lose
clear your mind must be we're gonna
teach you the boy has no patience
destroy the Sith we must a Jedi uses the
force for knowledge and defense you're
so powerful you are why he's the Grand
Master of the Jedi Order he's the oldest
and most powerful Jedi Master in 800
years he's had a hand in training almost
every Jedi
hee-yaw appear his pattern knows for
success I'll feel you cold sir afraid
are you
no sir
see through you we can be mindful of
your feelings your thoughts dwell on
your mother
I miss her afraid to lose her I think
hmm what does that got to do with
anything
everything clear is the path to the dark
side fear leads to anger anger leads to
hate hate leads to suffering
has sense much fear in you we'll never
get it out now
so certain are you always with you it
cannot be done you nothing that I say
master moving stones around is one thing
this is totally different
no no different only different in your
mind you must unlearn what you have
there all right I'll give it a try no
try not do I'll do not there is no try
to boost your feelings you
younglings younglings a visitor we have
hello I'm sorry to disturb you master
what helped an IV or be one hmm
I'm looking for a planet described to me
by an old friend I trust him but the
system's don't shown the archive Maps
hmm
lost a planet master obi-wan has how
embarrassing how embarrassing
Liam the shades gather round the map
reader near your minds and find
obi-wan's wayward planet we where it
ought to be here but it isn't gravity is
pulling all the stars in the area
towards this spot hmm
gravity's silhouette remains but the
star and all the planets disappeared
they have how can this be a thought
anyone master because I want erased it
from the archive memory truly wonderful
the mind of a child is the Padawan is
right go to the center of gravity's pull
and find your planet you will
I can't is to be size measurement look
at me that we know my size do you
hmm and where you should not for my Ally
is the force and Nepal for quiet ism I
have greeted makes it grow its energy
surrounds us and binds us illness beings
are we not this crude matter you must
feel the force around you you three do
me if we look everywhere
yes even between land the ship
you are the impossible
you
ah
you
believe it that is why you fail
premonitions premonitions
these visions you have to have pain
suffering death yourself you speak of or
someone you know someone close to you
yes
careful you must be when sensing the
future Anakin the fear of loss is a path
to the dark side I won't let these
visions come true Master Yoda death is a
natural part of life rejoice for those
around you who transform into the force
mourn them do not miss them do not
attachment leads to jealousy the shadow
of greed that is what must I do Master
you train yourself to let go of
everything you fear to lose I have
successfully made contact with the Prime
Minister of Kamino they are using a
bounty hunter named Jango Fett to create
a clone army I have a strong feeling
that this bounty hunter is the assassin
we're looking for do you think these
cloners are involved in the plot to
assassinate senator Amidala do not
assume anything obi-wan clear your mind
must be if you are to discover the real
villains behind this plot why would you
become to buy
most because of my father again ah
bugger ah for Jedi was he hippie hmm
powerful Jedi come on how did you know
my father you don't even know who I am
no I don't even know what I'm doing here
we're wasting our time I can teach him
the boy has no patience you loved
nations hmm much anger in him like his
father was I any different when you told
me there's not ready no
I am ready I bet I can be a Jedi Ben
tell him I'm right lady are you what
knows you ready for 800 years have I
trained Jedi they all count too well I
keep my who is betrayed he did I must
have the deepest the most serious mind
this one a long time have I watched all
his life that he looked away to the
Future to the horizon ever his mind on
where he was hmm what he was doing
Adventure hey I'm saved
hey hey Jedi craves not these things you
are reckless so was i if you remember
yes - oh hey dog to begin the training
hey but I've learned so much you finish
what he begins I won't fail you I'm not
afraid
yeah you will be you will be destroy the
Sith we must send me to kill the Emperor
I will not kill Anakin to fight this
Lord Sidious strong enough you are not
he is like my brother I cannot do it
twisted by the dark side young Skywalker
has become
the boy you trained gone he is consumed
by Darth Vader I do not know where the
emperor has sent him I don't know where
to look
use your feelings obi-wan and find him
you will get eye strength flows from the
force but beware of the dark saying
anger fear aggression the dark side or
something easily they throw but joy what
a way to start down the dark path
forever when I make the destiny consume
you it will get obi-wan to Prentice
Vader is the dark side stronger
but busier most napkin
but how I know the good side from the
bad you will know when you are called at
this passive a Jedi uses the force for
knowledge and defense never attack I
hear a new apprentice you have emperor
or should I call you Darth Sidious last
ayah you survived surprised your
arrogance blinds you Master Yoda now you
will experience the full power of the
dark side
I have waited a long time for this
moment
last the Jedi are no more not if
anything to say about it
I am at an end your rule is
and not short enough it was it's so
powerful you are
you will not stop me Da Vida will become
more powerful than either lost faith in
your new apprentice misplaced maybe as
is your faith in the dark side of the
horse
Master Yoda Count Dooku you have
interfered with our affairs for the last
time
powerful you have become Dooku and the
dark side I sense in you I've become
more powerful than any Jedi even you
much to learn you still have
it is obvious that this contest cannot
be decided by our knowledge of force
but by our skills with a lightsaber
like well you have my old bed run this
is just the beginning
thank you so much for watching us if
there's someone that you'd like us to
profile next please leave it in the
comments and we'll see what we can do
we'd also love to know which one of your
top ten rules made the biggest
difference for you leave it in the
comments below and join the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and we'll see you soon